let's add 19 and 3 18 to 18 and
two-thirds so i like to separate out the
whole number parts from the fraction
part so 19 and 3 18 is the same thing as
19 plus 3 over 18 and to that we are
going to add 18 and two-thirds which is
the same thing as 18
plus
two-thirds now we can separately add the
whole number parts so we could add the
19 to the 18. so we could do 19
plus
18 and then we can add the fraction
parts plus
3 let me do this in green plus 3 over 18
plus 3 over 18
plus 2 thirds
plus
two thirds now 19 over 18 pretty
straightforward that is what let's see
19 plus 19 would be 38 so there's gonna
be one less than that's going to be 37
so that gives me 37 and then 3 18 plus
two-thirds to add them i need to have
the same denominator and the least
common multiple of eighteen and three is
eighteen
so
let's convert two-thirds to something
over eighteen so two-thirds
two-thirds if i want to write it as
something over 18 well i multiply the
denominator by 6 so i'd also have to
multiply the numerator by 6. so it's the
same thing as 12 over 18. so i can
rewrite two-thirds as 12 over 18. and
now i can add these two things together
that's going to be so i have 37
plus it's going to be something over 18
plus something over 18.
3 plus 12 is 15 plus 15 over 18. and so
expressing this as a mixed number i get
37 and 15 18.
and that's the right number but we can
simplify it even more we can simplify
the 15 18. so both the numerator and the
denominator are divisible by three so
let's divide them both by three
and we're not changing the value because
we're doing the same thing to the
numerator and the denominator and so
this gives us we still have our 37
we still have our 37 but the numerator
is now 5 and the denominator is now 6.
so we get 37 and 5 6. 37 and 5 6. and
we're done